I just want to say is right as we start at the top of the show, I just want to say yeah, this is our 52nd episode of smart 22 that's a year in a year that's a one a year freaking year whole year God this is the 52nd episode of smart Oh my god, so yeah, let's get to it. This is I'm not sure if you guys are aware, but this is our 52nd episode which means we have hit one year one year started the nonsense Yeah, 52 weeks. Isn't that amazing is that incredible remember when we first started talking about doing this? Yeah, I do Yeah, I thought it was really just gonna be three four or five weeks Maybe something like that and then we'd a covert would be over and we'd be back to our our day jobs But god, this is thank you everyone for listening. Yeah, thanks
我只想说，在节目一开始的时候，我只想说，对，这是我们的“聪明”播客第52期，整整一年，天哪，这居然是第52期，哦天哪，那就开始吧。我不确定大家知不知道，这是我们的第52期，这意味着我们已经满一年了，开始胡闹的一年，对，52周。这难道不神奇吗，这难道不不可思议吗？还记得我们刚开始商量要做这个的时候吗？对，我记得。真的，我当时以为也就三四周、四五周左右，然后新冠就会结束，我们就能回去继续做各自的日常工作了，但天哪，感谢大家的收听。对，谢谢。
I'm letting will Sean and I continue to visit with one another every week Can I just say that friendship alive for me it? Really spending this last year with you guys in this way even more than the normal it's been a really great sort of antidote to it otherwise not amazing year and And being able to hang out with you guys has been fucking a real savior to me anyway for my mental health I really mean that likewise. It's been a nice thing to be able to count on once a week I feel so lucky to be even closer to you guys and have this experience to echo what will said together and And and and the opportunity to laugh together, which to me is life
让我和威尔、肖恩能够每周继续聚在一起聊天。我能说这维系了我的友谊吗？过去这一年以这种方式和你们在一起，甚至比平时还要好，这确实是应对那段本来并不美妙的日子的绝佳解药，而且能和你们这群家伙在一起混，对我的心理健康来说简直是一个真正的救星，真的。彼此彼此。能有这样一件每周都可以指望的美好事情，我感到非常幸运。我甚至觉得自己和你们更亲密了，有了这样的经历，呼应威尔刚才的话，能够一起欢笑，对我来说这就是生活。
Yeah, and it's not just the three of us Obviously, it's our it's our whole team and the other part of that team is Bennett barbecue and Rob Arm your and Michael Terry But we always know that Rob Rob's name is always Rob. I'm your arm your Is that how you say it Sean because Jason? Yeah, I like to say that the phonetic way I like saying Rob. I'm Jay Irv. Well, that's how it's spelled. Yeah, that's I'm saying that's instead of arm your Because even he doesn't know how you're supposed to say it like he doesn't even know how to say Rob Oh, he doesn't know how to say the Rob. I'm your arm your arm your Bennett barbecue. That's easy to say and Michael Terry That's easy to say. Yeah, but they make it happen. Those guys are fucking champs and honestly, it's
是的，而且不仅仅是我们三个人，显而易见，还有我们的整个团队。团队的另一部分成员有贝内特·巴比库、罗布·阿米尔和迈克尔·泰瑞。但我们总是知道，罗布·阿米尔的名字总是叫罗布·阿米尔。肖恩，是这么读的吗，因为杰森？对，我喜欢用拼读的方式来念，我喜欢叫罗布·杰·厄夫。好吧，拼是这么拼的。对，我就是这个意思，而不是叫“阿米尔”（Arm your），因为连他自己都不知道该怎么念他的名字，比如他甚至不知道怎么念罗布的名字。哦，他不知道怎么念罗布·阿米尔、阿米尔、贝内特·巴比库。那个挺好念的。还有迈克尔·泰瑞，那个也好念。对，但他们让这一切成为可能。那些家伙真是太棒了，老实说，这……
We wouldn't be here without that. I want to see I want to see the socials line up and appreciation for Bennett Rob and Michael Yeah, truly honestly sincerely. Thank you to anyone who has been spending some time with us and Yes, letting us keep the the lights on as I think they say yeah and putting up with our nonsense and knowing that we're just here Having fun just like you guys honestly. I'm so glad you guys don't have to pay for this. It's free. It's priced, right? But we can but we can announce right Jason. We can't officially say that we are gonna do a Smartlist tour a line. You're doing a smart list tour. We're going on tour. That's right. We're smart list is going on tour We are going to six cities in North America. Yes, we have a ton to discuss dates venues even a special promo code for our listener Yeah, yeah, but but that's too much to make our guest wait for so that's gonna be at the end
如果没有他们，我们今天就不会在这里。我想看到社交媒体上排起长队，向贝内特、罗布和迈克尔表达感激。是的，千真万确，发自内心地感谢每一个花时间陪伴我们的人，是的，正如他们所说，让我们能够继续开门营业。还有容忍我们的胡闹，并且知道我们来到这里只是为了像你们一样开心。老实说，我真高兴你们不用为这个花钱。这是免费的。价格正合适。不过我们可以宣布了，对吧，杰森？我们可以正式宣布，我们将要进行一场“聪明”播客巡演了。真的吗？你们要进行“聪明”播客巡演？我们要去巡演了。没错，聪明播客要开启巡演了。我们要去北美六个城市。是的，我们有大量的事情要讨论，日期、场地，甚至还有给我们听众的专属优惠码。对，对，但是，但是这些内容不能让我们的嘉宾等太久，所以这些会在最后公布。
But right now, okay, we got to get to what might be our greatest of all time Oh, oh, yeah, we have with us someone that would be best described as a true force He's taken the gifts he's been given and the influence he holds and pointed them towards a full menu of things That are truly too long to mention in an intro However, a couple to throw out there would be the creation of a world-class elementary school and a family foundation He's part owner will of one of the world's most famous soccer teams. What and he has starred in five films He's married to his high school sweetheart. He has three kids. He was recruited to play football by Notre Dame But instead this fool took a gamble on basketball where he just can't seem to find any success guys
但现在，好吧，我们必须请出可能是有史以来最伟大的人物。哦，哦，对，我们今天请到的这位，用“真正的力量”来形容他最合适不过了。他将自己被赋予的天赋和拥有的影响力，倾注于数之不尽的事情中，如果在开场白里全部列举出来实在是太长了。不过，随便挑出几个来说，就包括建立了一所世界一流的小学和一个家庭基金会。威尔，他还是世界上最著名的足球俱乐部之一的联合老板。什么？他还主演了五部电影。他娶了他的高中挚爱。他有三个孩子。他曾被圣母大学招募去打橄榄球，但这个傻瓜却去赌了一把篮球，结果他在篮球界好像怎么也找不到任何成功，伙计们。
Please meet mr. LeBron James Did I have you fooled that was good intro right there Jason that's pretty good intro You've never been introduced like that before right people go on about Jason. That was a good one It's a good one. Oh my god But truly let let me tell you something LeBron going through and I don't do a lot of research as the guys will attest I will go to a Wikipedia page though your page is more of a book and I just I just hit effort real quick I didn't know where to begin. There's so much stuff But truly the stuff about philanthropy and family and all that stuff
请欢迎勒布朗·詹姆斯先生！我刚才把你唬住了吗？刚才那个开场白很不错吧，杰森？这开场白相当不错。你以前从来没有受过这样的介绍吧，人们对杰森赞不绝口。那是一个很好的介绍。这真的很好。哦天哪！但说真的，让我告诉你一件事，勒布朗，我浏览了资料——正如小伙子们所证明的那样，我其实不做太多研究，不过我会去看维基百科页面，然而你的页面更像是一本书，我当时赶紧点了一下，都不知道该从哪里开始，里面有太多东西了。但真的，关于慈善事业、家庭和所有这些事情……
We're gonna get into because I think everyone else knows the other stuff, but men go ahead Well, you got something to say first of all, I was gonna say I just took off. I was wearing a Lakers t-shirt This is crazy I just took it off because I worked out and you don't want to get into my workout routine LeBron because it's I bet he'd love to get it. Well, these shoulders, you know, they don't quit. I mean What about the Liverpool element that was a real shocker to me that's you know, I'm not a smart guy But will did you know that who wills a huge soccer fan LeBron? I read that I'm a big Liverpool I'm a big Liverpool supporter and and I have been for a number of years and I'm friendly with a bunch
我们接下来会深入聊聊，因为我觉得其他人对其他事情都已经很了解了。不过，男人，你先说，威尔，你是不是有话要说？首先，我要说的是，我刚刚脱掉了一件湖人队的T恤。这太疯狂了，我刚把它脱下来，因为我刚刚锻炼过。勒布朗，你可不想了解我的锻炼日常，因为我敢打赌你会很想了解的。好吧，这肩膀，你知道的，它们从不罢工。我是说，关于利物浦的那个元素，这对我来说真是一个巨大的震惊，你知道的，我不是个聪明人，但是威尔，你知道吗？威尔是个超级足球迷，勒布朗？我读到过，我是利物浦的超级球迷，好多年都是，而且我和那里的很多人……
But I had read that you were part owner, which is so crazy because I'm like another thing that LeBron and I have in common Oh, yeah, there it is. Shoulders and the soccer stuff Dominating the shoulders in Liverpool. LeBron, I have to say this is This is especially exciting for me because I know who you are. Oh, yeah We've had a few athletes on the show and and Shawn just goes to he starts playing Candy Crush and we pick it up After the guest goes away Thrilling I I I can't believe you're here. This is so exciting. Thank you No, I have so many things I want to say for to ask you that I've just thought about one of the things is
但我读到过你是联合老板，这太疯狂了，因为我想“勒布朗和我还有另一个共同点”。哦，对，就是这个。肩膀和足球。在肩膀和利物浦方面占据主导地位。勒布朗，我不得不说，这对我来说特别令人兴奋，因为我知道你是谁。哦，真的吗？我们节目上过一些运动员，而肖恩只会去玩糖果传奇，等嘉宾一走，我们就接着录。太激动人心了。我简直不敢相信你在这里。这太令人兴奋了。谢谢。不，我有很多话想对你说，想问你，我刚刚想到了一件事，其中之一就是……
You're such an incredible Jason's right. You are a force and you've been such an incredible You're so iconic already, which is which is crazy because you're you're still a relatively young man a lot younger than we are We can be his dad. We could be his dad But you've done you've done so much and and it's and it's so impressive to watch you do it and you do it with such There's a grace about you because you the part of the problem I think about being on top and I wouldn't know but part of the problem is that you are subjected to a lot of you know Slings and arrows, you know from from people from all sides not the least of which is I think every year since you Got drafted people are like, who's the greatest of all time? Is it like they have there's a poll every six hours
你太不可思议了，杰森说得对。你真是一股强大的力量，你已经如此具有标志性了，这太疯狂了，因为你仍然是一个相对年轻的人，比我们年轻得多。我们都可以当他爸爸了。我们都可以当他爸爸了。但你已经做了这么多事情，看着你做这些，真的非常令人印象深刻，而且你带着一种优雅在做。因为我认为身处巅峰所带来的问题之一——虽然我不会懂——但部分问题在于，你要承受来自各方的许多冷嘲热讽，其中最不容忽视的是，我想从你被选中开始的每一年，人们都在问：“谁是有史以来最伟大的？”就像每隔六小时就会有一个民意调查。
ESPN will put it on their page like and who is LeBron greater than Michael Jordan? It's like guys. He's LeBron He's his own person that that shit must get exhausting be honest. It must be exhausting No, it can it can't be exhausting. Well, I mean you said it but um, you know I've always looked at it like anytime you compared or you even mentioned with the greats that ever played this game It's just become humbling for me because you know the same people they put me in a category with or saying Compare this compare this to that guy or the same guys that I looked up to for inspiration when I was growing up And I needed that inspiration, you know growing up in the inner city here in Akron, Ohio So, you know to have you know, the Michael Jordan's and to have the you know
ESPN会把它发在网页上：“勒布朗比迈克尔·乔丹更伟大吗？”就像是，伙计们，他是勒布朗，他有他自己的个性。老实说，那破事一定让人精疲力竭，一定很累吧？不，它不会令人精疲力竭。我是说，你这么说了，但是……你知道的，我一直这样看待它：任何时候你被拿来比较，甚至被同曾经在这个游戏里打过球的伟大人物相提并论时，这对我来说只会变得让我感到谦卑。因为你知道，那些把我归入同一类的人，或者说把我和那个人进行比较的人，正是那些我在成长过程中寻找灵感时仰望的人。我当时需要这种灵感，你知道的，我在俄亥俄州阿克伦市的内城区长大。所以，你知道的，能拥有迈克尔·乔丹，能拥有科比·布莱恩特，能拥有小肯·格里菲和迪恩·桑德斯，所有这些难以置信的体育人物，你知道的，当我需要的时候，他们帮助了我。所以，这就好像是，哇，你们竟然把我和我成长时期见过的这些最伟大的球员相提并论，这真的太让人感到谦卑了，老实说。
The Kobe Bryant's to have King Griffey juniors and a Dion Sanders all those Unbelievable sports figures, you know what when I when I needed it, you know, they helped me So it's like wow you guys are comparing me to these greatest players that I've ever seen when I was growing up It's just like it's such humbling man. Yeah, the the stats will certainly Put you in that category without even trying but what you've what you've done off the court the stuff You don't need to do but you find yourself drawn to do and as a result of your success on the court Has given you access to do and the capital to do. I find really really admirable I'm envious of it
这些数据绝对会让你不用费力就能进入那个范畴。但你在球场外所做的事情，那些你不需要去做、却发现自己被吸引去做的事情，是你由于在球场上的成功而获得了去做这些事的途径和资本，我真的非常非常钦佩这些。我很嫉妒这一点。
There's a there's a drive though that that has to fuel that because you're tired all bet doing the stuff That is your day job. How do you find Jason's tired for you? I'm sure you have a great infrastructure of people that can identify some Charitable endeavors that are worthy of your time and and and the attention that you can put on them I'm sure you rely on them a bit But a lot of that's got to be your own self-drive and to motivate those people to be diligent in how they assess certain Charitable organizations and whatnot. Well, where does that drive come from that that that drive of philanthropy? Now you just I mean you said it Jason
不过，背后一定有一种驱动力在支撑着这些，因为做那些并非你日常工作的事情，你肯定已经很累了。你是怎么找到的？杰森说你很累。我确信你身边有一个很棒的人才网络，能够帮你识别出那些值得你投入时间、给予关注的慈善事业。我确信你有点依赖他们。但其中很大一部分肯定源于你自身的驱动力，去激励那些人在评估某些慈善组织等方面保持严谨。那么，这种驱动力从何而来？那种慈善事业的驱动力？现在你刚才——我是说，你说了，杰森。
I think for me that the drive comes from my upbringing and You know growing up the way I grew up, you know, I'm a part of a single parent household just me and my mother no siblings You know not much care my mom worked on and off, you know my whole Childhood so, you know every day was kind of a struggle for us as a family So I felt that if I ever was even put into a position This is also part of my inspiration to growing up if I was ever put in a position where I succeed at doing anything And I can make any kind of dollars anything as far as capital that I want to give a lot of it back I want to give a you know a lot of it back to my community
我想对我来说，这种驱动力来自于我的成长经历。你知道的，以我那种方式长大，我是单亲家庭的一员，只有我和我母亲，没有兄弟姐妹。你知道的，没得到太多的照顾，我妈妈在我整个童年时期时断时续地工作。所以，你知道的，对我们这个家庭来说，每一天都有点像是一种挣扎。因此我觉得，如果我哪怕有朝一日能处于这样一个位置——这也是我成长过程中灵感的一部分——如果我能处于一个在任何事情上都能取得成功的位置，并且能赚到任何资金、任何我想要回馈社会的资本，我想把很大一部分回馈出去。我想把很大一部分回馈给我的社区。
Because I understand what those kids are going through on a day-to-day basis because I've walked those same streets I've tackled those same corners. I know the hardships of what a single parent household kid could feel like and the Pressures and the adversity and all that stuff that comes with it. So and to see that change. Yeah. Yeah I mean see the change of happen from your efforts. It's got to be Unbelievably rewarding. Yeah, I mean yeah, we to hear some of the family shawning like well, you know you guys I mean just to see some of the families come and tell, you know, either You know the falconty members that's at my school or the teachers that you know
因为我理解那些孩子们日复一日正在经历的事情，因为我走过同样的街道，我经历过同样的街角。我知道单亲家庭的孩子可能会感到的艰难困苦，以及伴随而来的压力、逆境和所有这一切。所以，看到这种改变发生……是的，我是说，看到你的努力带来的改变，那一定极其有成就感。是的，我是说，是的，听到一些家庭的声音，肖恩，就像是，你知道的，伙计们——我是说，仅仅看到一些家庭走过来，告诉学校里的教职员工，或者那些——你知道的。
I've changed their lives or tell my mother because now my mom is huge into the foundation and she welcomes a lot of issue part of it What yes, she's a she's like one of the head advisory boards of my foundation where I basically have an apartment complex here as well Yeah, where I welcome a lot of the underprivileged families in and we set them up with Roman board You know that we're not in a position where they came, you know, afford their own living. So, you know, it's pretty cool My mom welcomes all these families in that's awesome. So she's set kind of like an ambassador. Yeah, exactly But you say like you came up, you know, you talk about your own childhood and record to recognize look I really struggled and so I want to be able to give back and really do it in a way in a really practical way Lot of people talk about it, but you actually do it
我改变了他们的生活，或者告诉我的母亲，因为现在我妈妈非常热衷于这个基金会，她欢迎很多人加入其中，她也是其中的一部分。是啊，她就像是我基金会的核心顾问委员会成员之一。在这里，我基本上也建了一栋公寓大楼，在那里我欢迎许多底层的贫困家庭入住，我们为他们安排食宿，你知道的，因为他们自己负担不起生活。所以，这相当酷。我妈妈欢迎所有这些家庭入住。那太棒了。所以她有点像是个大使。是的，完全是。但你刚才说你出身贫寒，你谈到自己的童年并意识到：“听着，我真的经历过挣扎，所以我想有能力回馈社会，并且以一种非常务实的方式去做。”很多人只是说说而已，但你真的去做了。
And you know look at Sean Sean grew up you had a tougher, you know childhood and stuff and you turned your back on your community Yeah, he went the other way. He kept things simple He lives in a mansion and he spends his money on No, but surely free though. Yeah, and Jason doesn't know what the what you know Jason jumped the line famously to in line for the first iPhone. So like we all have our own Let me just say this to you you could have a single incarnation But my point is this my point is you could have gotten you you've had everything you've had so much success You could have just sailed away on a yacht and never looked back
而且，你知道的，看看肖恩，肖恩长大时你的童年也很艰难，而你却背叛了你的社区。对，他走向了反面。他把事情搞得很简单，他住在豪宅里，把钱花在……不，但完全是免费的，对吧？是的，而且杰森也不知道这是怎么回事——杰森当年为了买第一部iPhone，大张旗鼓地插了队。所以，我们都有自己的……我只想对你这么说：你可以拥有单一的生命历程，但我的意思是，你可以拥有这一切，你取得了如此巨大的成功，你完全可以坐着游艇扬长而去，再也不回头。
But he's finding time to do that too, right? We get some yacht hours each year. Yes Wait, have you been on a yacht with LeBron and you haven't told Oh, but I know how to get to the Daily Mail, right? I mean So so you're a kid so you're a kid you're hanging out and you're thinking boy If I can ever get this jump shot to really go down in a consistent way I might be able to get myself to a place where I could either get out of here or stay here and and and help Give back to this man. What was the moment when you thought to yourself? Oh, you know what this is gonna work And I think I've got a very realistic chance of making it and now I'm starting to think about what I'm gonna do
但他也会抽出时间做那件事，对吧？我们每年都有一些游艇时光。对。等等，你跟勒布朗一起坐过游艇，而且你没告诉过……哦，但我知道怎么联系《每日邮报》啊。所以，所以你还是个孩子，你四处闲逛，你心想：“天哪，如果我能让这个跳投真正以稳定高效的方式命中，我可能就能让自己到达一个地方，要么能离开这里，要么能留在这里，然后帮助回馈这个男人。”当你想着“哦，你知道吗，这行得通，而且我觉得我有一个非常现实的机会成功，现在我开始考虑如果我成功了我要做什么”时，那个时刻是什么时候？开始制定关于慈善事业的计划——你知道的，因为很多小孩子在学校里都会幻想“我长大后想当个老师，这样就不用做任何学校作业了，我还能拿到——”那种时刻是怎样的？你还记得最初的那些计划吗？有过那样一个时刻吗？是的，我觉得是的。在我高三刚开始的时候，我16岁。所以那是在我高二结束后的那个夏天，正要升入高三的时候，我登上了《体育画报》的封面。
If I do make it starting your plans about Philanthropy and you know because a lot of kids fantasize in school when I'm older I want to be a teacher so I don't have to do any of the schoolwork and I can get like what was that moment like and what were Those first few plans you remember that was there a moment. Yeah, I feel like yeah the beginning of my junior year I was 16 years old and so it's right after my sophomore year in the summer going into my junior year. I was on the cover of Sports Illustrated That'll do it. They doubt they dubbed me the chosen one at 16 years old And a lot of pressure by the way, no pressure Right, right and the jinx of the cover on top of it all right right and the jinx of the cover
那可真行。他们在16岁时给我冠以“天选之子”的称号。顺便说一句，压力很大。没有压力，对吧，对吧？而且顶着封面的魔咒，对吧，对吧，顶着封面的魔咒。
And so a lot of NBA execs were talking and they were saying that you know if I entered the draft You know right now I could be the number one pick and you know, but you know do it all those things so I felt like I seen the success that I was having and The reason that I knew I wanted to come back and give back to my community is because I knew the success that I was having Yes, it had to do with my God-given abilities and my talent and me putting in the work But the support that I had for my coaches and my friends and my mom They stayed on my ass every day like listen. Yeah, this is what we're going. This is what we doing We all listen. We have an opportunity to make this bigger than even what other people are saying
所以很多NBA高管都在讨论，他们说，如果我当时参加选秀，我可以直接成为状元秀，你知道的，诸如此类的事情。所以我觉得我看到了自己正在取得的成功，而我知道我想回来回馈社区的原因是，我知道我所取得的成功，是的，这与上帝赋予我的能力、我的天赋以及我的努力有关，但我也得到了教练、朋友和妈妈的支持。他们每天都盯着我的屁股，就像是：“听着，是的，我们要去这里，我们正在做这个。我们大家，听着，我们有机会把这件事做得比其他人说的还要大。”
Let's not fuck it up right? Oh You know, so, you know, it's tough on a 16 year old because listen me and my friends we want to do You know first year driving we want to go to house parties We want to go, you know, we hang with the other high school kids and do kid things, but you know Yeah, right, you know Jason knows about the kid things right like driving off the Warner Brothers lot when you're 16 But with your but LeBron with with your kids your own kids What an incredible story you have to pass down to them about your struggle and then how you turn it around and how you're giving back Is it something that they get and if they don't get it you grind it in their brains?
“我们可别把它搞砸了，好吗？”哦……你知道的，所以，对一个16岁的孩子来说这很难，因为听我和我的朋友们，我们想做——你知道的，刚到法定开车年龄，我们想去参加家庭派对，我们想去，你知道的，和其他高中生一起玩，做小孩子做的事，但是，你知道的……是的，对吧，你知道的，杰森很懂小孩子做的事，比如16岁时把车开出华纳兄弟片场。但勒布朗，对于你的孩子们，你自己的孩子们，你有着多么不可思议的故事可以传给他们，关于你的挣扎，然后你是如何扭转局面以及你如何回馈社会的。这是他们能理解的事情吗？如果他们不理解，你会把这些硬灌进他们的脑子里吗？
It's like you've got to keep looking at me. You've got to keep looking at my story. You have got to learn how to give back I mean, it's so cool to have a dad that That does all that there's absolutely nothing I can do Nothing I can do to give them the same moment or aspirations or like drive that I had It's just to I mean you can't teach ambition. No, I can't I know I grew up in Akron, Ohio in the inner city You know and the hood is what we call it the projects and my kids are growing up four years in Miami on South Beach And now four are going on five years in Brentwood. So Yeah, you know and when we were here for those four-year run when I was in Cleveland, they were younger
就好像是：“你们得一直看着我，你们得一直看着我的故事，你们得学会如何回馈社会。”我是说，有一个能做到这一切的爸爸真是太酷了。绝对没有什么事是我可以做的，没有什么事是我可以做来给他们同样的时刻、抱负，或者像我那样的驱动力的。这根本……我是说，你无法教出雄心壮志。不，我不能。我知道我在俄亥俄州阿克伦市的内城区长大，你知道的，我们称之为贫民窟、廉租房区，而我的孩子是在迈阿密南海滩度过了四年，现在又在布伦特伍德度过了快五年。所以，你知道的，当我还在克利夫兰效力时，我们在那里度过了四年，他们当时还小。
You know, we're in it. We're now in the suburbs So I went to public schools and challenging public schools until I got the high school because of my basketball ability But these kids are growing up in private schools. So the one thing that I can do is it's still of the morals And what we do in this house? Yeah, and this is how you need to represent yourself when you leave the house as a young man I got two boys two teenage boys. I got a daughter that's seven years old So you give them the blueprint and then you got to let them, you know, we I hope that they have some adversity You know, they need some hardships They hope they find some along this way because you really only know who you are and you only gonna be able to come back from
你知道的，我们身处其中。我们现在住在郊区。所以，直到因为我的篮球天赋进入高中之前，我上的都是公立学校，而且是很有挑战性的公立学校。但这些孩子是在私立学校长大的。所以，我能做的一件事，就是灌输道德观念，还有我们在家里做事的原则。是的，这就是你作为一个年轻人离开家时需要展现自己的方式。我有两个男孩，两个十几岁的男孩。我还有一个七岁的女儿。所以，你给他们蓝图，然后你必须让他们，你知道的——我希望他们经历一些逆境，你知道的，他们需要一些艰难困苦，我希望他们在这个过程中能遇到一些，因为你只有通过经历才能真正了解自己，并且只有经历才能让你从……
Situations because the best teacher in life is experience. Yeah. Yeah, and I bet you lean on mom a lot too, right? Your wife I bet your wife is Incredibly important to with all the time you're spending on the road I mean, I the three of us know as well The amount of time you spend away from home is immense and you really have to lean on your your partner To like my wife is part-time dad too, you know, yeah for sure They're literally the boss of the household like we're we're gone so much We all know that that it's hard for us to come home and be like, okay. This is the hell we doing
因为生活最好的老师就是经验。是的，是的，我敢打赌你也非常依赖妈妈，对吧？你的妻子，我敢打赌你的妻子也极其重要，考虑到你花在路上的所有时间。我是说，我们三个人同样心知肚明，你花在远离家的时间是巨大的，你真的不得不依靠你的伴侣——就像我妻子也是个兼职爸爸一样，你知道的，当然。他们字面意义上就是家里的老大，因为我们离开的时间太长了，我们都知道，我们很难回到家里然后说：“好吧，这就是我们正在做的操蛋事，这就是我们要这么做的原因。”就像是：“爸爸，你已经连续离开四五个月了，就像是——”好吧，是的，就像妈妈已经告诉过我们的那样：“坐下吧，爸爸。”你的孩子会遇到一点逆境，比如开着车从布伦特伍德出来碰上傍晚的车流，巴灵顿大道简直……
This is how we doing it like dad you've been going for four or five months straight like like dad Okay, yeah, like mom already told us go sit down dad Your kids are gonna have a little bit of adversity with that that sunset traffic coming out of Brentwood The Barrington is just And now back to the show, you know, you do all this stuff and you've got this school Where you you provide opportunities and Jason brought it up I love the way by the way as you were talking about growing up you kept saying We you know that the people who are around you're saying we have an opportunity we have an army
现在，回到节目中来。你知道的，你做了所有这些事情，你有了这所学校，你在其中提供机会。杰森提到了这一点——顺便说一句，我真的很喜欢你刚才谈到自己成长经历时一直说“我们”。你知道的，你身边的那些人说：“我们有机会，我们有一个军团……”
You know, we got to keep going We got to keep doing the things the way that you were part of something and that you relied like as you talked about these people That you leaned on I love that you talked about in that way I think it's so Important to sort of to have that kind of support system But as you talked to kids who don't have the job shot that you had as you what do you say to those kids who are like look man I hit the lottery. I had a tremendous amount of skill. I had great people around me I'd God-given gifts and I had the willpower to do it. That was the perfect storm
你知道的，“我们得继续前进，我们得继续做事”，就像你曾经是某个集体的一部分，你依赖着——正如你所谈到的那些你所依靠的人，我真的很喜欢你以这种方式谈论它。我认为拥有那种支持系统是如此重要。但是，当你对那些没有你那样的投篮绝技的孩子们说话时，当你——你对那些孩子们说些什么呢？他们会觉得：“看吧，伙计，我中了彩票。我拥有极其惊人的天赋，我身边有很棒的人，我有上帝赋予的天赋，我还有去做的意志力。”那简直是一场完美的风暴。
That's not going to be the experience for ninety nine point nine percent of the kids No question. No question about it. That's the one thing that we have like at my school here We don't we don't even have a basketball complex at my school, you know, but we have we have a art We have an art room. We have a music lab. We have a technology lab world computers Like so like we're we're we're every single day asking our kids What do you want to do, you know, a lot of them say sports but a lot of them like listen I want to be a doctor, you know So we have doctors that come in to talk to our kids a lot of them say, okay
对于百分之九十九点九的孩子来说，那绝不会是他们的经历。毫无疑问，毫无疑问。这就是我们在我的学校里所拥有的东西——我们甚至在我的学校里都没有篮球馆，你知道的，但我们有艺术室，我们有音乐实验室，我们有配备世界一流电脑的技术实验室。所以，我们每天都在问我们的孩子们：“你想做什么？”你知道的，他们当中很多人说想搞体育，但也有很多人说：“听着，我想成为一名医生。”所以我们有医生来跟我们的孩子们交流。很多人说：“好吧，我想当一名警察。”
I want to be a cop, you know We got cops, you know Obviously at the front door when they walk in it's so kind to our kids and they can talk to them and give them guidance Like what do you want to be like what do you want to be? What's your aspirate? What are your dreams? You might not even know what your aspirations are right now, but you do have dreams We all had dreams about what we wanted to be so, you know, if it's something that they have passion about We try to bring it to the school and try to give them the resources to you know, let's let's see if we could tap into it and We might you might fail that first one, you know, let's let's try it again
当他们走进前门时，警察就站在那儿，他们对我们的孩子们非常友善，孩子们可以跟他们交谈并获得指导：“你想成为什么样的人？你的志向是什么？你的梦想是什么？”你现在可能甚至不知道你的志向是什么，但你确实有梦想。我们所有人对于自己想成为什么样的人都有过梦想。所以，你知道的，如果那是他们充满热情的事情，我们会尽量把它带到学校里，并尽力为他们提供资源，让我们看看能不能挖掘出潜能。你可能在第一次时会失败，没关系，让我们再试一次。
Or you might say I don't let's try something else, you know, that's all about being a kid You try so many things until you finally figure out. Okay. Oh, this is what I want to do And then let's try to give them the resources. That's that's my whole thing I want to just give them the resources to be able to tap into whatever they want to do I love that and now I want to get I want to ask you stuff about playing in the game because you know I played basketball when I was a kid and I was like, I'd be like buying a child No, I did and and I was like when everybody went when the ball would be Here we go
或者你可能会说：“我不喜欢这个，让我们尝试点别的。”你知道的，这才是当孩子的意义所在。你要尝试很多事情，直到你最终弄清楚：“哦，这就是我想做的。”然后让我们试着为他们提供资源。这就是我的全部想法。我只想为他们提供资源，让他们能够去追求他们想做的任何事情。我太喜欢这个了。现在我想问你一些关于打比赛的事情，因为我知道我小时候也打过篮球，而且我当时觉得——我会像个孩子一样……不，我真的打过。当每个人都去争球的时候——这就对了。
When you did when you're talking when you're saying the LeBron you're describing playing basketball the LeBron James I'm sorry. I interrupt. So when I was a kid I played about your experience playing basketball I played basketball and whenever there was a rebound and everybody would run to the end of the other opposite end of the court I'd go go. No, you guys go. I'll catch. I'm right behind I'm so close. I'm I'm I'm just gonna take a beat, but I'm right behind you guys But wait, but here's the thing But I look at you because I've been to a couple Lakers game live courts I was lucky enough to have courtside seats and see you
当你做的时候——当你谈论勒布朗时，你正在描述打篮球的勒布朗·詹姆斯。对不起，我打断一下。所以当我还是个孩子的时候，我打过篮球，每当有篮板球的时候，每个人都会跑到球场的另一端，我会说：“去吧，你们去吧，我接着。我就在后面，我很近，我只是稍微放慢一下节奏，但我紧跟在你们后面。”但是，等等，关键是这样的。不过我看着你，因为我现场看过几次湖人队的比赛，坐在场边。我很幸运能坐在场边座位看你打球。
I have to say seeing seeing seeing you play live and seeing the whole team play life is so much more thrilling than TV But TV is thrilling too, but to see it live. It's just unbelievably exciting and and I don't I couldn't even possibly begin to understand How you do what you do, but here's the thing here comes a question guys. It's worth the wait When you're running death, I mean it seems like it's you get tired Yeah Endless amount of energy who cuts the oranges to the parents take turns I'm bringing oranges for half-time
我不得不说，亲眼看你打球，看整个球队现场打球，比看电视刺激多了。虽然看电视也很刺激，但现场看简直是难以置信地令人兴奋，而且我甚至无法开始去理解你是如何做到你所做的事情的。不过，问题来了，伙计们，这绝对值得等待。当你奔跑时——我是说，看起来你似乎会累。无穷无尽的能量。是谁切的橙子？是家长们轮流带来的吗？我带了半场休息吃的橙子。
You've been doing it for so long tired No, God LeBron, I got a question Here's now. What about what about your foot? Wait, I want to know about injuries. My whole point was asking about injuries Okay, so I'm obsessed with medical stories, right? I I host another podcast It's called a hypochondria actor because I'm an actor who's a hypochondria anyway, and and I just wanted to know What kind of injuries have ever had what was the worst one you've ever had where you and did you play through it?
你打了这么久，不累吗？天哪，勒布朗，我有个问题。现在，问题来了。你的脚怎么样？等等，我想知道关于伤病的事。我问伤病的事的整个重点在于……好吧，我对医疗故事着迷，对吧？我主持另一个播客，叫做《疑病演员》，因为我是一个有疑病症的演员。不管怎样，我只是想知道你受过什么样伤，你受过的最严重的伤是什么？你带伤坚持打过吗？
The worst injury I had tore my groin Two years ago. How does that have a plan all Christmas Day in Golden State? Shawn did the same thing in Mika nose Yeah But it was so worth it Sitting up there and hit hard. Oh My I swear if I was in Mika nose it's on my groin. I've been working too. I'll tell you daily mail would love it Oh, I know I did not keep playing. I feel like my balls was ripping off. Yep
我受过的最严重伤是两年前腹股沟撕裂。那是怎么……在金州打圣诞大战时弄伤的。肖恩在米科诺斯岛也干过同样的事。但那真的很值得。坐在那儿，重重地撞了一下。哦，天哪！我发誓如果我在米科诺斯岛，我的腹股沟就撕裂了。我一直在锻炼。我告诉你，《每日邮报》会爱死这事的。哦，我知道。我当时没有继续打。我感觉我的蛋都要被撕下来了。是的。
Oh Really yeah Something that I think is very very interesting among many things is Randy Maverick and Rich now now fellas These are these are three of his best friends from growing up and you guys figured out a Sort of a four-legged table to go through the rest of your life and everyone kind of talked about I would imagine What their lanes would be and how we can be a unit and we can drive this thing? What was what was what were those conversations like and how early did that start? Well, let's start. I mean it was it was early on after my
哦！真的吗？是的。我认为在众多事情中非常非常有趣的一点是，兰迪、马弗里克和里奇。现在，伙计们，这是他从小到大的三个最好的朋友，你们琢磨出了一张类似于四足桌子的组合，来应对你们余下的人生。我猜每个人都讨论过自己的擅长领域是什么，以及我们如何才能成为一个统一的整体并推动这件事情发展。那些对话是怎样的？这开始得很早吗？嗯，开始得很早。我的意思是在我在NBA的……
My rookie year in the NBA. I Realized that 19 years old that the representation that I was under at that time Wasn't best suited for me and it wasn't gonna allow me to grow not only as a basketball player But also as a I wanted to you know be a businessman as well. I wanted to get control of my my business and it was something that was Unprecedented and shone upon in the NBA because everyone always expects for you to have a agent NBA agent But when I you know part of ways with my NBA agent and agency and started my company LRMR with Maverick rich and Randy People were like they're uneducated. They don't know anything about the sports world. They don't know anything about business It is gonna be a complete disaster
在NBA的新秀赛季之后，我在19岁时意识到，当时管理我的经纪团队并不最适合我，它不会允许我成长，不仅作为一个篮球运动员，而且作为一个——我也想成为一名商人。我想掌控我的生意。这在NBA是史无前例且备受白眼的，因为每个人都期望你有一个NBA经纪人。但当我与我的NBA经纪人和经纪公司分道扬镳，并与马弗里克、里奇和兰迪一起创办了我的公司LRMR时，人们说：“他们受教育程度低，他们对体育世界一无所知，他们对商业一无所知，这绝对会是一场彻底的灾难。”
For me, I didn't give a damn about what they were talking about because I feel like if I'm Who are the people to trust more than the people that I know? And we can all learn together because I don't want to to learn at a rate Then now these guys are so far below me, then how can I ever bring them into any room? Let's all learn at the same time. Let's learn at the same rate. Let's take bumps and bruises Let's take let's fail at the same time while we all going along in this journey So when we get to a point where oh, we've done so much. We've learned so much. We've experienced You know failure, but we've done it together. So we know how to we you know, when the next point come up
对我来说，我才不在乎他们在谈论什么，因为我觉得，如果我要信任某些人，还有谁比我认识的人更值得信任呢？我们可以一起学习，因为我不想以一种速度学习——以至于这些家伙远远落后于我，那我以后怎么把他们带进任何房间里？让我们所有人同时学习，以相同的速度学习。让我们一起经历磕磕绊绊，让我们在这次共同的旅程中一起遭遇失败。这样当我们走到某个节点时，我们会说：“哦，我们已经做了这么多，我们学到了这么多，我们经历过失败，但我们是一起经历的。”所以我们知道如何去面对——你知道的，当下一个节点出现时，我们知道如何去攻克它。所以，你知道的，这就是我的全部心态。
We know how to attack it. So, you know, that was my whole mindset I think it's just incredible that not only were you guys successful at that you didn't fall on your face They did negotiate great contracts for you. You have found incredible business opportunities But I'll bet what you're probably most proud of is that you were able to navigate all of that and still maintain the friendship that it I'm sure it got complicated at times But that you guys stayed so close and so trusting and probably felt very equal Everybody respected each other. I mean, I'm sure that takes a ton of work. It's like a marriage, right? No, absolutely I mean every day every single day and we're still going I mean and we're still, you know
我认为这简直不可思议，你们不仅在那件事上取得了成功，没有颜面扫地，他们确实为你谈判出了伟大的合同，你还找到了不可思议的商业机会。但我敢打赌，你最自豪的可能是，你能够驾驭这一切，同时还能维持这段友情——我确信有时情况会变得复杂——但你们依然保持着如此紧密的联系、如此的信任，并且可能感到非常平等。每个人都互相尊重。我是说，我确信这需要大量的努力。这就像是一场婚姻，对吧？不，绝对是的。我是说，每一天，每一天都是如此，而且我们还在继续。我是说，我们依然在——我们涉足这个领域已经快20年了，但我的意思是，我们相对而言都还很年轻。我是说，很明显我是这群人里年龄最小的，但我36岁了，我的兄弟们刚40出头或45岁左右。而且，你知道的，我们现在处于一个很好的位置。但我们想继续攀登，因为这——你知道的，我们想要继续建设，建立关系，并为每个人创作出色的内容。
We've been in this for almost 20 years now, but I mean, we're all relatively still young. I mean, I'm obviously I'm the youngest out of the crew But I'm 36 my guys are in there, you know early 40s or mid 40s And you know, we're in a good place today But we want to continue to climb because it's you know, we want to continue to build and build Relationships and and build great content for for everyone. Yeah, yeah And you get to do with the people you get to do with the guys like you said that you trust But who are your friends and that's nice and we go through the same thing here I mean, we get to do this podcast with I get to do with two guys that I love and who are my friends and I'm not the youngest
是的，是的。而且你能够和你信任的人一起做这件事，正如你所说，和你的朋友们一起。这很好，我们这里也经历着同样的事情。我是说，我们得以和两个我爱的人、也是我的朋友的人一起做这个播客，而且我不是最年轻的……
But I I'm I sort of I'm not in my I play 38, but you know, I'm sort of I don't think so I mean, I could probably or like a 40 or just like a kind of a rugged 40 But the point is We we get to do and I get that and that's it's part of the experience I mean, you might as well do the experience the way you want I love the way you also you answer that like you're like people say that you guys didn't know what you're doing You don't know the sports world and all that stuff and you're like, I don't give a damn like who gives a shit There are always who gives it their life is way too short
但我——我有点像是不在我的——我演38岁，但你知道的，我有点——我不这么认为。我是说，我可能看起来像40岁，或者只是一种饱经风霜的40岁。但重点是，我们得以做到这一点，我理解这一点，这是体验的一部分。我的意思是你最好按照自己想要的方式去经历这一切。我也很喜欢你回答那个问题的方式，就像是人们说你们不知道自己在做什么，你们不懂体育世界之类的话，而你的反应是“我根本不在乎，谁在乎呢？”人们总是——生命太短暂了。
And that was kind of like my earlier question like it's part of the problem about being on top is people always have Opinions and you hear it all the time and you you do, you know In credit you have a lot of people who support you and you're so great at what you do But you always have this really organic kind of natural way about you and you're very much You're very authentic and that comes across and I think that that's so admirable It's send such a great message of like all these all these critics to people who want to I remember though Do you remember the the decision Sean? Do you know what the decision was? So when LeBron was gonna leave Cleveland the first time he was deciding and tell me if I got it wrong or whatever
这有点像我之前的问题：身处巅峰的部分问题在于，人们总是会有意见，你随时都能听到这些，而且你——你知道的，不可否认，你有很多支持你的人，你做你所做的事情是如此出色，但你身上总是带有一种非常有机、非常自然的特质，你非常真实，而这一点能够展现出来，我认为这太令人钦佩了。这传递出了这样一个伟大的信息：所有这些批评者，那些想要——不过我记得，你还记得那次决定吗，肖恩？你知道“决定”是什么吗？所以当勒布朗第一次要离开克利夫兰时，他在做决定，如果我记错了或者别的什么，请告诉我。
But I think this right and you're deciding where you were gonna go And there were people who criticize it who still to this day. Yeah have time on their hands enough They want to go back Relitigate something from 15 it was international news that whole thing. Yeah, I was So what let him do it how he wants to do it. Yeah, he's not it. He's not your experience. Why are you mad about it? Yeah, yeah, I love that buddy, man, you know, so at the end of the day, I mean, you know You'd be so successful you try to be so successful to where when we reap the benefits I do with my friends So, you know, when I see Sean and Mika knows and I'm with my guys that we can all
但我认为这是对的，你当时在决定你要去哪里，而有些人对此进行了批评，直到今天他们依然——他们有闲工夫去重新清算一件15年前的事情。那是国际新闻，整件事都是。是的，我当时想，就让他按他想的方式去做吧！是的，这不是你的经历，你生什么气呢？是的，是的，我喜欢这个，伙计，你知道的，所以到头来，我的意思是，你知道的，你要么变得极其成功，你要么努力变得非常成功，以至于当我们收获果实的时候，我和我的朋友们一起分享。所以，你知道的，当我看到肖恩在米科诺斯岛，我和我的兄弟们在一起时，我们可以——我们可以一起撕裂腹股沟，然后吃点……
We can all tear our groins together and have some So when you're talking about having success and having the the courage to try to have success in other areas one of the things You said was content and of course you got Space Jam coming up which looks incredible Yeah, where where does this drive for for entertainment for for acting producing and all that stuff Were you always a fan of the entertainment industry? Is that something that that just kind of grown? Yeah Jason always man When I was a kid, you know, not only was the inspiration coming from like sports figures There was also coming from like, you know TV shows that I was watching like I always felt like I wish I was the fresh Prince of Bel Air, so I was I was the Fresh Prince of Akron, Ohio, you know, I was in the suburbs of Akron, Ohio and Bath Township
所以当你在谈论取得成功、并拥有在其他领域尝试成功的勇气时，你所说的事情之一就是内容。当然，你接下来还有《空中大灌篮》，看起来棒极了。是的，你对娱乐、表演、制片以及所有这些事情的热情是从哪里来的？你一直都是娱乐行业的粉丝吗？这是那种逐渐滋养生长的东西吗？是的，杰森，真的。当我还是个孩子的时候，灵感不仅来自于体育人物，还来自于我看的那些电视节目。我总是觉得，我希望我能成为《贝尔莱尔的新鲜王子》，所以我就是俄亥俄州阿克伦市的新鲜王子。你知道的，我在俄亥俄州阿克伦市的郊区，巴斯镇。
And I could you know look up to a mansion, you know cover from the inner city like the Fresh Prince of Brentwood Yeah, yeah, the Fresh Prince of Brentwood like I've always I love that storyline or like, you know I wish you know at times like, you know, it's you know, just being in certain movies like action movies and things that nature growing up so like Yeah, like the the the passion of watching that and seeing that and being a kid like just trying to find any inspiration That's where it kind of came from and I've always kind of respected that I did not had no idea of the damn hours that you guys Hours but I always let me ask you this like look at what Dwayne Johnson has done. Could you ever see yourself? What at some point retiring and then starting and having an incredible career as an action star in movies?
我可以仰望豪宅，从内城区走出来，就像布伦特伍德的新鲜王子一样。是的，是的，就像布伦特伍德的新鲜王子。我一直——我喜欢那个故事情节。或者就像，你知道的，有时你会想，你知道的，就是出现在某些电影里，比如动作电影和诸如此类的事情中。所以随着年龄的增长，观看和看到这些并作为一个孩子试图寻找任何灵感，就是从那种地方开始的。我一直对那种东西保持着敬意。我当时完全不知道你们这些该死的小时数……但是我会——让我问你这个，看看道恩·强森所做的事，你能不能想象自己有一天退休后，开始并在电影中拥有一段作为动作巨星的不可思议的职业生涯？
I'm not against that. Yeah, I mean listen to rock man Dwayne Johnson is incredible He's I mean shit. I was watching him when he was in the WWE, right, you know growing up and he had all the he had all the hair at that time, you know But you but you but you could crush that LeBron LeBron you'd be fantastic I've seen you act you you get it you absolutely get it And you've got all the charisma and the size to be carrying around two or three weapons When you I remember when you first hosted SNL my my ex-wife at the time Amy was on the show I remember I was kind of we actually met briefly I wouldn't expect to remember but we at the time everybody talking about how natural you were kind of to what Jason was saying
我不反对那个。对，我的意思是听着，岩石巨石强森太不可思议了，他，我的天。我以前看他摔角，在WWE的时候，对吧，你知道，那时候他还在成长，那时候他头发还很茂密，你知道的，不过你可以搞定那个，勒布朗，勒布朗你肯定棒极了。我见你演过戏，你懂的，你绝对懂。而且你很有魅力，身材也够魁梧，能随身携带两三件武器。我记得你第一次主持《周六夜现场》的时候，我当时的前妻艾米也在节目里。我记得我们当时还稍微见过一面，我本来不指望你还记得，但当时每个人都在谈论你表现得有多自然，有点像杰森说的那样。
Like you were really great on that episode. Yes Thank you. Yeah, yeah I just wanted to have a hello, but I like having a great time man and just diving into it and you know I like like comedies That's like really my thing because I'm a fucking Jokester with me and my friends and all we do is like rank on each other and joke on each other But it's fun man. What's the thing that's making you laugh right now? Are you are you watching a show or a movie or what's what's your what's your brand of humor?
就像你在那一期节目里表现得真的很好。是的。谢谢。对，对，我本来只是想打个招呼，但我喜欢玩得开心，伙计，只想全身心投入其中。你知道的，我喜欢喜剧，这真的是我的菜，因为我他妈就是个爱开玩笑的人，我和朋友们在一起时，我们只会互相开涮、开玩笑。但这很有趣，伙计。现在是什么东西在逗笑你？你最近在看什么节目还是电影？或者说，你的幽默风格是什么？
Are you more of like a money Python silly guy or or more more cerebral kind of dry humor? I'm a little bit of everything. So I'm a I'm a I'm a Seinfeld funny guy. Yeah, I'm also like a Wedding Crashers funny guy, right? Yeah I'm like and I'm every a road trip kind of guy. Oh, like I'm any I'm all of that like and I'm also like like scary movie Like those type of right. Yeah, silly Yeah, yeah all over the genre of comedies Yeah, and where are you taking a lot of these in on the plane in between games or you a kind of guy that sits at home and nests and Just gets all comfy on the couch. Yeah, I'm a guy that gets comfy on the couch
你是那种巨蟒剧团式的无厘头，还是更偏向理性、略带讽刺的干冷幽默？我各种风格都有点。所以，我是那种《宋飞正传》式的幽默搞笑咖。对，我也挺像《婚礼傲客》里那种搞笑的，对吧？对，我甚至还是那种公路电影风格的家伙。哦，就像是，只要是这类的我都喜欢，而且我也喜欢那种……比如《惊声尖笑》那种类型的，对吧？对，无厘头，对，对，各种类型的喜剧我都看。对，那你平时都在哪看这些？在飞机上，在比赛间隙？还是那种喜欢坐在家里筑巢、在沙发上舒舒服服躺着的人？对，我是那种喜欢在沙发上躺得舒舒服服的人。
That's what I'm gonna do. I would a glass glass of wine on the couch. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah, for sure Now do you let your kids watch our rated comedies? I do my boys do how old were they when you let them start to watch stuff That was really kind of edgy edgy comedy cuz I'm dealing with that right now with my 14 year old daughter Yeah, yeah, I'll let I'll let my my boys start watching around like 10. Yeah 11 years old. Yes, my daughter can watch certain but not I don't let her watch just she's only six going on seven So I'm gonna wait till she get a little older. Where are you on cursing my kids? Wait, Jason, what did you just let your franny watch something? What was it? It's pulp fiction and
这就是我要做的。手里端着一杯红酒躺在沙发上。对。没错，没错。那么，你允许你的孩子们看R级喜剧吗？我允许。我的男孩们可以看。他们多大的时候你开始让他们看那种比较边缘、尺度有点大的喜剧的？因为我现在正面临这个问题，我14岁的女儿……对，对，我会让我的男孩们大概10岁、11岁左右开始看。是的，我女儿可以看某些内容，但不能全看。我不会让她随便看，她才六岁快七岁了，所以我打算等她再大一点。对于说脏话这件事你怎么看？等等，杰森，你刚才让你的弗兰尼看什么了？那是什么？是《低俗小说》和……
She was confused in a couple of spots and I didn't bother The epi-pen yeah Jason and this weekend are you guys you're you're we aren't this weekend Aren't you guys watching human centipede? Wait, wait LeBron, where are you on cursing my 14 year old? I'm allowing her to now I haven't started complaining about her cursing or else, you know, she's not like a like a like a sailor, but You know, she's just casually using the s-word or the f-word or whatever And I'm like, well, I guess I was doing that afford or she's doing that with her friends So why can't you do that with us? Where are you with that the kids kids?
她在好几个地方都感到困惑，而我懒得去解释。等等，杰森，这个周末你们是不是打算去看《人体蜈蚣》？等等，等等，勒布朗，对于在我14岁女儿面前说脏话这件事，你持什么态度？我现在允许她这么做了。我没有开始抱怨她说脏话，否则，你知道的，她说话不像个水手，但你知道的，她只是偶尔用一下“s”开头的词或者“f”开头的词什么的，然后我想，好吧，我想我以前也会那样，或者她是在跟朋友们一起时那样，所以为什么你不能在我们面前也这样呢？对于这个，你怎么看，孩子们，孩子们？
Walking around the house. So my boys are they have an exception to the rule of cursing when they're playing sports So they can curse when there's playing sports. Yes, because yes, they could curse when they play in sports Because it's a lot of emotion. I get it, you know, but then you get teed up, right? Yeah, you know, they can get teed up But they don't my kids don't mess with the refs much But like if they you know missing assignment, they say fuck or they like or something have a damn or shit like, you know But but my oldest son and his past tournament over the 4th of July weekend a kid was talking a little smack to him Oh, and he told him to fuck off and I started laughing
在屋里走来走去。所以我的男孩们，他们在打体育比赛时有说脏话的特例，所以他们在打比赛时是可以说脏话的。是的，因为，是的，他们在打比赛时可以说脏话，因为情绪太激动了。我懂，你知道的，但那样的话你会被罚出场的，对吧？对，你知道的，他们可能会被罚出场。但他们不怎么跟裁判争执。不过，如果他们漏掉了战术防守，他们会说“他妈的”，或者说类似“见鬼”或“靠”之类的话，你知道的。但是，我的大儿子在7月4日独立日周末的那场比赛中，有个小孩对他说了点垃圾话，哦，他对那小孩说“滚开”，然后我忍不住笑了。
I saw you in that tournament and the reason I saw you is because it was on like one of the on the internet and I'm thinking like Who's letting these photos be taken of this high school basketball game? Like what is going on? Oh my god? Are there photographers or yes, yes, there's what's families with phones? No, they really had no there were families with big lens cameras like their own set really Trying to capture this stuff and sell it to the internet. Yeah, they capture it. They yeah. Yeah, so yep. Yep Maybe you should turn around and tell them to fuck off Right, I should take a page out of my son's book So wait, so so if he spills a cereal in the house and he says god damn it son of a bitch, that's not okay
我在那场比赛里看到你了，我之所以看到你，是因为它被发到了网上，当时我在想，谁在放任别人拍这种高中篮球比赛的照片啊？这到底是怎么回事？哦，天哪！有摄影师吗？有，有，有拿着手机的家属？不，他们真的有，不，有家属拿着长镜头相机，就像他们自己带的一样，真的是为了捕捉这些画面然后卖到网上。对，他们捕捉到了，对。所以，也许你应该转过身去叫他们滚开。没错，我是该从我儿子那里学点经验。所以，等等，如果他在家里洒了麦片，然后他说“真他妈见鬼，王八蛋”，那就不行了，对吧？
Right, that's when he's got to go to his room. Yeah Hey, what the hell you talk? Oh, oh, sorry And if you were to punish him what what are the punishments like with my kids? It's got it you take away the iPad and that that straightens them out. What's what's the kryptonite there? We tried taking away his video game system before Okay, he still had his phone right and then without his phone. He okay, didn't he had his company had his iPad Yeah, and then he had his desktop if he didn't have his desk. He had his desktop They what are you gonna do? Sending them to the room is actually not a punishment. They know
对，那种情况下他就得回自己房间去了。对。嘿，你们在聊什么鬼？哦，哦，抱歉。如果你要惩罚他，惩罚通常是怎么样的？对于我的孩子们，必须得没收他们的iPad，这招能治得服服帖帖的。你们的克星是什么？我们以前试过没收他的游戏机。好吧，但他还有手机啊，对吧？然后没收了他的手机，好吧，他还有iPad，然后他还有台式电脑。如果他连台式电脑也没有，那他还有……你们能怎么办？把他关在房间里其实根本不算惩罚，他们乐意呢。
Yeah, yeah, they want to be in the room. Yeah, I'll just tell them come downstairs They sit down here with mom and dad just come sit down here with mom and dad. That's that. Tell us about your day I say if you guys don't if you don't you know smart enough, but I make them FaceTime with Sean Yeah They shape up real quick. They really shape up quick and Jason you had an instant Didn't one of your daughters spill some electrolytes recently and you got That was a tough moment for you And now back to the show
对，对，他们就想待在房间里。对，我只会告诉他们下楼来，坐到这儿，跟爸爸妈妈坐在一起，就坐到这儿陪爸爸妈妈。就这样。给我们讲讲你今天过得怎么样。我说，如果你们不……你们明明挺聪明的，但我会逼他们跟肖恩进行FaceTime。他们立刻就老实了。他们真的马上就学乖了。杰森，你刚才遇到了一件急事，你的某个女儿最近是不是洒了电解质饮料，然后你……那对你来说是个艰难的时刻。好了，言归正传。
Talking about electrolytes doing my incredible research abroad what tell tell us about ladder. What's ladder? Yeah, one is so ladder is a supplement It's a powder form supplement that you put into water Has electrolytes. We also have like pre and post workouts. So what happened was in 2012 I caught cramps during the NBA finals and my legs. I could not get the cramp out So I was able to work with some scientists from Harvard and some other Institutions and we was able to find all organic product that
说到电解质，我做了极其充分的研究，勒布朗，给我们讲讲Ladder吧。Ladder是什么？对，其中一个是……所以Ladder是一种补剂，是你可以倒进水里的粉末状补剂，含有电解质。我们也有赛前和赛后补剂。所以当时的情况是，在2012年，我在NBA总决赛期间抽筋了，我的双腿抽筋抽得怎么也缓不过来。于是我得以和来自哈佛以及其他机构的一些科学家合作，我们找到了一种纯天然的产品……
Helps out with the electrolytes and it gets to the system faster and it stopped. I haven't had I haven't had that problem in nine years After that, so I want some of that. So we have I'll make sure I get something to you guys I'm Jason you guys Jason. We got it recorded here. I'm gonna make sure I get some ladder to you guys Yeah, I would love that LeBron. I want to know like, you know Everybody associates you with the obvious things that we see like the talent and basketball the talent on the screen when you decide to act So what is the thing that would be so surprised like would I ever find you at the Hollywood Bowl listening to some classical music? You know what's funny shot that you say that I love classical music Oh, yeah, I really do like if you if you if you would have happened to pull up on the side of me when I'm not in the dark dark tent car
它有助于补充电解质，能更快地被身体吸收，并且它止住了抽筋。在那之后的九年里，我再也没有遇到过这种问题。所以我想要点那个。所以我们有……我一定会确保给你们带点产品的。杰森，你们听着，杰森。我们这都录着呢，我一定会确保给你们带点Ladder的。太好了，勒布朗，我很想知道，你知道的，每个人都会把你想成那些我们显而易见能看到的东西，比如篮球天赋，当你决定演戏时的银幕天赋。那么，有什么事情是会让人大吃一惊的呢？比如，我会在好莱坞露天剧场找到你在听古典音乐吗？肖恩，你知道最好笑的是什么吗？我其实很喜欢古典音乐。哦，真的吗？我真的很喜欢。如果你恰好开车从我旁边经过，而我不在那辆贴了黑膜的车里……
Yeah, you can catch me out of light listening to some old Beethoven Mozart come on. That's as opposed to the new ones. Yeah You know that I'm fully I'm fully addicted to that stuff and so is Sean Sean's a classically trained pianist, right? Yeah, yeah Wow, but that's cool. I love that now Are you ever listening to classical music on your headphones as you're getting ready to play or you listen to something? That's that gets gets the blood flowing a little bit more. No, I'm listening something get the blood flowing a little bit more Yeah, sure and that's sure and that changes each game
对，你可能会在红绿灯路口看到我在听一些老贝多芬、莫扎特的曲子。拜托，比起那些新歌……对，你知道的，我完全沉迷于那种东西，肖恩也是。肖恩是一个受过古典音乐训练的钢琴家，对吧？对，对。哇，这太酷了，我喜欢这个。那么，你在准备比赛时，会戴着耳机听古典音乐吗？还是会听一些能让血液循环更快、更嗨的音乐？不，我会听一些让血液循环更快一点的音乐。对，当然。而且每一场比赛都不一样。
Or is there like a go-to that if you if you need to really get it going? Yeah, like who is it? Do you want to share it? It's not a go. It's like it changes. It's not a go-to You know, you know, I'm listening to a lot of like hardcore hip-hop, you know It could be like either Wu Tang or it'd be like, you know, some some DMX some early DMX I'm sure it's an NWA, you know I want to get to a real or even like Eminem like when he was doing his thing like at a higher level too So like, you know, I tap it to it to a whole another I'm not the father at home with the kids LeBron when I tap it to that mode I'm like get the hell out of my way. I'm ready. I'm ready for war. I'm ready for war. Yeah
还是说有什么必听曲目，如果你真的需要调动状态的话？对，比如是谁的歌？你想分享一下吗？没有固定的必听曲目，它一直在变。没有固定的，你知道的，我经常听很多硬核嘻哈，你知道的，可能是武当帮（Wu-Tang），或者也可能是，你知道的，一些DMX，早期的DMX。我敢说还有NWA，你知道的。我想找回那种状态，甚至是阿姆（Eminem），当他在巅峰时期火力全开的时候。所以，你知道的，我能切换到一种完全不同的状态。勒布朗，当我在家和孩子们在一起时，我不是那种爸爸。当我切换到那个模式时，我会觉得：别他妈挡我的路，我准备好了。我为战斗做好了准备，我为战斗做好了准备。对。
You should listen. You should listen to our podcast right before the game Just with your headphones on and you're coming in that's gonna give you the fighting spirit Tell us a little bit about about Space Jam before we before we let you go You've been very generous with your time But I'm very very curious about about this because that's that was a great first film this this this one is Is it pick up where it left off? How is it? How is it different on what? No, it's nice It's different. First of all, it's totally different from the first one that came out 25 years ago But yeah, I was very intimidated just from when I got when the script came to me and I sat it on my desk
你应该听。你真该在比赛前听听我们的播客，就戴着耳机，然后入场，那会给你带来战斗精神。在我们放你走之前，跟我们聊聊《空中大灌篮》吧。你对时间的安排非常慷慨，但我对这个真的非常非常好奇，因为那是部很棒的第一部电影。这一部，它是承接上一部的剧情吗？它是怎么样的？它有什么不同？不，很棒。它很不同。首先，它和25年前上映的第一部完全不同。但是，是的，当剧本送到我手上并放在我桌上时，我内心非常忐忑。
I was very intimidated just because I understand, you know, the legacy behind the first one You know, I was I was one that was like it all of it I was 12 years old or 11 when it first came out and love the Looney Tunes Obviously my aspiration for Michael Jordan is out of this world. So very intimidated But I was able to get myself to a point where I was like I want to I want to do this I felt like, you know, the Space Jam legacy is so Iconic and so great. I wanted to be a part of the legacy and obviously the the movie is now called a new legacy It's kind of how I want myself out, but we was able to I worked with a great director of Malcolm Lee
仅仅是因为我理解第一部背后的传奇色彩，我感到非常敬畏。你知道的，当它上映时我12岁或11岁，绝对超爱乐通。显然，我对迈克尔·乔丹的崇拜无以复加，所以我非常敬畏。但我最终调整好了自己的心态，对自己说：我想做这件事。我觉得《空中大灌篮》的传奇色彩是如此标志性、如此伟大，我想成为这个传奇的一部分。显然，这部电影现在叫《新传奇》（A New Legacy），这有点像我自己的写照，但我们成功做到了。我和一位伟大的导演马尔科姆·李合作过。
Don Cheeto is in the film as well He's great. Yeah, so I love him. He's helped me out a lot when we were on set, but I just dove into it I gave him, you know, everything to it How'd you like working with all that green screen and all that, you know, I need you to look over here and just trust that later We're gonna we're gonna paint in a little character. You got to look at like a little C-stand with an X on it Exactly. It's like working with Sean. Just a nightmare, right? Yeah, working with Sean. Yeah, or you mean the green screen. Yeah, green screen gives more No, it was a nightmare the first few weeks. Yeah, of course. It's weird, right?
唐·钱德尔也在电影里，他也很棒。是的，所以我很喜欢他。我们在片场时他帮了我很多，但我全身心地投入了进去，我为它付出了全部。你喜欢和那些绿幕打交道吗？你知道的，那种“我需要你看向这边，然后相信稍后我们会画上一个小角色”的拍法。你得盯着一个上面画着X的小C形支架。完全是这样。这就像跟肖恩合作一样。简直是一场噩梦，对吧？对，跟肖恩合作。是的，或者你是说绿幕。对，绿幕带来的不只是……不，前几周简直是噩梦。对，当然。这很诡异，对吧？
It's so it's super weird because they're like, no, no, no, you're I you're you're you have to be looking up So is that was that like a three-picture deal or we're gonna see how the first one goes or what did you do? Is it just the one? No, no, it was just the one But I mean listen, I've been hearing so much about people's reaction to it so far that's actually seen the movie so far We got an opportunity to private screen it so, you know, if Warner, you know wants to, you know, tackle it again I wouldn't mind, you know, trying to see we could fit the right script in and and keep it going But I think this one is gonna it's gonna surprise a lot of people. This is a family movie It's a family movie with a lot of laughs. Obviously a lot of looniness. I'm dealing with the damn tunes. They crazy
太诡异了，超级诡异，因为他们会说：“不，不，不，你现在必须往上看。”所以，那是一份三部曲的合同，还是说我们先看看第一部反响如何，或者你签了什么？难道只拍这一部吗？不，不，就这一部。不过，我的意思是，到目前为止，我听到太多关于看过这部电影的人的反馈了。我们有机会做了一场私人放映，所以，如果华纳（兄弟）想要，你知道的，再拍一部的话，我不介意看看我们能不能敲定一个合适的剧本，然后把它延续下去。但我认为这部电影会给很多人带来惊喜。这是一部合家欢电影。这是一部充满欢笑的合家欢电影。显然还有很多滑稽的元素。我在跟那群乐通开心果打交道，他们太疯狂了。
Is your daughter excited about it or are your son's a little too old for it or what? My daughter is super excited about it She doesn't know I mean she's too young to know about the original tunes But now because of her dad she's getting back into it now Was she on the set and was she like wow, yeah, yeah, yeah My whole family stopped by set, you know a few times and they just like wow and my boys is 16 or 14 They only care about how cool that the person that's playing them in the movie looks like dad Does he look like me? Is he wearing my hairstyle? Is he dressing the right way?
你女儿对这部电影感到兴奋吗？还是说你的儿子们觉得它有点太幼稚了？我女儿超级兴奋。她还不知道……我的意思是，她太小了，不知道最初的乐通是什么样。但现在因为她爸爸的关系，她开始重新接触这些了。她去过片场吗？她当时有没有发出“哇”的惊叹？对，对，对。我的全家人都去片场探过几次班，他们只是不停地说“哇”。我儿子们一个16岁，一个14岁，他们只关心电影里扮演他们的人看起来酷不酷：“他看起来像我吗？他留着我的发型吗？他穿衣服的方式对吗？”
Like I don't want somebody playing me and not like so you so you cast some actors to play your sons Yes, we cast the actors to kind of look like my family. We change the names But they are yes, I got an older son a younger son and a daughter and a wife in the movie So yes, it's kind of the same your kids didn't have approval over that casting No, I didn't let them because they would it would have took too long I said dad got to get on the work I and after after a long hours did they did you mix them up? Oh the kids? Yeah, I'm almost brought my fictional family home one time
就像我可不想找个人来演我却不像……所以你选了一些演员来演你的儿子们？对，我们选了一些看起来像我家人的演员。我们改了名字，但是是的，电影里我有一个大儿子、一个小儿子、一个女儿和一个妻子。所以是的，差不多就是这样。你的孩子们没有对选角拥有决定权吧？不，我没让他们选，因为那样会花太长时间。我说：“爸爸得去工作了。”在经历了漫长的工作之后，你有没有把他们弄混过？哦，孩子们？对。我有一次差点把虚构的家人带回家。
Long as I don't bring the fictional wife home. I was good. Yeah, right So so LeBron, let me ask you after all this stuff and everything you're doing get back to basketball You've had a lot of success with the Lakers already I don't want to put you on the spot, but I mean you could conceivably just keep going You're so good at what you do. You're still at the top of the game How long do you see yourself playing for the Lakers and how cool is it playing for the Lakers a great storied franchise? Yeah, yeah, I mean listen I truly hope that I can finish my career with the Lakers and how many years that is if it's four or five six
只要我没把虚构的妻子带回家就行了。没问题。对，没错。所以，勒布朗，让我问你，在经历了这一切以及你所做的一切之后，重新回到篮球场上。你在湖人队已经取得了很大的成功。我不想让你陷入尴尬，但我的意思是，你完全可以继续打下去。你太擅长你所做的事了。你仍然处于巅峰状态。你觉得自己还会为湖人队效力多久？为湖人队这样一个有着辉煌历史的豪门效力究竟有多酷？对，对，我的意思是，听着，我真的希望我能在湖人队结束我的职业生涯。不管那是四、五年、六年……
Whatever seven we go, you know, I hope I could continue to play the game You know, I love being in LA my family loves being LA being with a historical franchise like the Lakers or something like it's like me You know being in space gym now I never thought it'd be possible you think about Kareem and magic and will and Jerry Weston and Elgin Baylor Kobe Shaq all the whole list Goes on so Lewis cage, you know, Lewis cage, you know, the great Lewis cage Greatest Lakers fan of all time He's like the greatest Well LeBron can't thank you enough for spending some time with us man. Appreciate you guys
还是七年，随它去吧，你知道的，我希望我能继续打球。你知道的，我喜欢住在洛杉矶，我的家人喜欢住在洛杉矶。效力于湖人这样历史底蕴深厚的豪门，或者类似的事情，就好像……你知道的，我现在就在《空中大灌篮》里，我以前从来没想过这是可能的。你想想贾巴尔、魔术师约翰逊、威尔特（张伯伦）、杰里·韦斯特、埃尔金·贝勒、科比、奥尼尔，整个名单长得数不过来。还有路易斯·凯奇，你知道的，路易斯·凯奇，伟大的路易斯·凯奇，史上最伟大的湖人球迷，他就像是最伟大的……好吧，勒布朗，真的非常感谢你抽空跟我们聊天，伙计。谢谢你们，伙计们。
That was really exciting. What a thrill We're all huge huge fans of yours and feel very very flattered that you chose spend some time with us So thank you. I appreciate Jason will shine. I appreciate man. Hopefully see you guys in person soon man. Yeah, that'd be great Yeah, all right, pal wait man. Such a fan Guys, thank you. Bye. Bye. I Could have talked to him all day, but I wanted to respect his his time He had a hard out and I think we just we were like one minute over it But man, I could I could talk to him forever. Yeah, what a cool guy. What a cool career. He's had so far
那真的很令人兴奋。太刺激了。我们都是你的超级超级粉丝，并且对你选择抽空和我们聊天感到非常非常荣幸。所以谢谢你。我很感激，杰森和肖恩。我很感激，伙计们。希望很快能跟你们当面见面，伙计们。对，那太棒了。对，没问题，老兄。等等，伙计。真的是你的粉丝。伙计们，谢谢你们。拜拜。拜拜。我本可以跟他聊上一整天，但我想要尊重他的时间。他有严格的离开时间，而且我想我们大概超时了一分钟左右，但是天哪，我能跟他聊到地老天荒。对，真是个超酷的家伙。他拥有多么酷的职业生涯啊。
I have to be honest like I was floored LeBron James like looking at James and living legends so crazy One of the he was one of the earliest people I sent to to Michael our producer to see if we could get and I honestly had Forgotten that I'd put him down as one of the people I'd left to grab on my list And then he sent me a text a couple days ago saying so LeBron's people reached out they can do it on this day But only this time I was like, oh my god, that's right LeBron. Jane Like I've been like a panic for like 36 hours like we're we're gonna be talking to LeBron James and then doing the research looking at his I just like and screw this. I just I can't
我必须得说，我当时简直惊呆了。勒布朗·詹姆斯，看着詹姆斯，活着的传奇，太疯狂了。他是最早的一批人选之一，我让我们的制作人迈克去看看我们能不能请到他，而且老实说，我差点忘了我把他写在了我想在我的名单上抓住的人之一。然后他几天前给我发了一条短信说：“勒布朗的团队联系了，他们可以在这一天，但只有这个时间。”当时我想：“哦，天哪，没错，勒布朗·詹姆斯。”就像我恐慌了大概36个小时，想着我们要和勒布朗·詹姆斯对话了，然后做研究，看着他的资料，我只想……算了吧，我实在……
There's too much there's it's it's it makes your neck I mean after like only it was only a couple weeks ago that we had to throw and then now we have It's I know because we were so Scraping with Justin in his stories about it growing up, and I don't want to get all the MVP's Justin has gotten You know what I mean, but the rose That way Justin's Wikipedia page Mike That's wrote in himself. There's is you know, there's a there's a there's a comparable element there on the shoulders I don't know why but whenever we meet like just huge gigantic celebrities like LeBron James
信息量太大了，这让人脖子发酸。我的意思是，仅仅在几周前我们还不得不进行推测，而现在我们真的拥有了……我知道，因为我们一直在和贾斯汀讨论他成长过程中的那些故事，我不想历数贾斯汀拿过的所有MVP奖杯，你知道我的意思吧，但那种成长经历……贾斯汀的维基百科页面，迈克，那是他自己写的。那里有……你知道的，这里面有一种可以相提并论的元素。不知道为什么，每当我们遇到像勒布朗·詹姆斯这样超级巨大的名人的时候……
I'm so surprised that like they're just normal and down-to-earth people like he's so down to earth even though He's he's literally huge and gigantic. Yeah, yeah, and off the earth He's spent a lot of time off the earth in the air. Yeah, he's got great great leaps are incredible vertical Yeah, all right, but you know we are very generous with our oh my gosh This person was so great, and we love them and they're so down to earth, but genuinely this guy I mean he could he doesn't need to talk to us. He doesn't even know And Jason you're right. We do we do do that a lot We do do that a lot of a lot of the episodes were like oh my god
我都无比惊讶于他们竟然是如此正常和接地气的人。他真的太接地气了，尽管他字面意义上身材高大魁梧。对，对，而且他经常不在地球上，在空中。对，他有着极佳的弹跳，垂直起跳简直不可思议。对，没错，但是，你知道的，我们非常大方地夸奖……哦，天哪，这个人太棒了，我们爱死他了，而且他如此接地气。但说真的，这家伙，我的意思是，他根本不需要和我们说话，他甚至都不认识……杰森，你说得对，我们确实这么干过。我们真的在很多期节目里都这样，当时我们就想：“哦，天哪！”
This person was so great, and we do feel that way in the moment. We're not lying We we really like the people but but this guest could literally qualify as the greatest of all time, and yeah He could he could I could go on forever, but let's not let's let's give the listeners what we promised Which was a little bit more detail on our tour. Yeah, let's start with a tour. Yeah, sorry Let's get back to the tour. Let's get back to the tour. We're going to six cities So we start in Toronto Massey Hall Wednesday February the 2nd and then February 4th We go to Boston, Massachusetts at I'm not sure how to pronounce it Bach or botch Center Wang theater the Wang theater Yep, and then February 5th Brooklyn, New York at Kings Theatre. Yeah, February 8th Chicago, Illinois at the Chicago theater
这个人太棒了，我们在当时确实是那种感受。我们没有撒谎，我们真的很喜欢这些嘉宾。但这位嘉宾简直可以说是史上最佳，而且，是的，他绝对可以……我可以没完没了地说下去，但我们别这样，还是把我们承诺过的内容带给听众吧，那就是关于我们巡演的更多细节。对，我们从巡演开始讲起。对，抱歉。让我们回到巡演上来。让我们回到巡演上来。我们要去六个城市。所以我们从多伦多的马西音乐厅（Massey Hall）开始，2月2日星期三，然后2月4日，我们去马萨诸塞州波士顿的……我不确定该怎么发音，伯克（Bach）还是博奇中心王剧院（Wang Theatre）？王剧院。对。然后2月5日，纽约布鲁克林的国王剧院（Kings Theatre）。对，2月8日，伊利诺伊州芝加哥的芝加哥剧院。
Yes, Sean, and then where are we going February 9th? Jason, can you guess we're driving? Yeah, we are driving We're gonna we're to dress we're gonna fly between those cities and then from Chicago We're gonna just up the up the coast there a little bit the Lake Coast It's not really on the coast. No, it's more sensual. It's nowhere near the coast, but go ahead Well the coast of the coast of the lake, right? Sure. Sure. No, you're thinking Milwaukee, but no, where are we going? We're gonna end up going Madison, Wisconsin At the Orpheum theater to see Tracy my sister Wednesday February 9th Tracy You better start laying out your outfit right now because you're coming up on stage and then we end on February 12th
是的，肖恩。然后我们2月9日要去哪里？杰森，你能猜到我们要开车去吗？对，我们要开车。我们要……我们要坐飞机穿梭于这些城市之间，然后从芝加哥出发，沿着海岸线往上走一点，湖岸线。其实也不是真正的海岸线。不，更偏向内陆，离海岸线十万八千里，不过你继续说吧。湖岸，湖岸对吧？当然，当然。不，你想的是密尔沃基，但不对，我们要去哪里？我们最后要去威斯康星州麦迪逊的奥菲姆剧院（Orpheum Theatre）看特雷西，我的妹妹。2月9日星期三，特雷西，你最好现在就把演出服装准备好，因为你要上台了。然后我们在2月12日结束巡演。
Which is Saturday in coming Los Angeles, California at the Orpheum theater, right and just like the show We we can't announce who the guests are those will be a surprise Surprise on the night, but here's what's really really cool for you guys Who have been so awesome and kind and loving to be listening to us all the time We wanted to give you guys something in exchange, which is a head start on tickets So if you go to smartlist.com and put in the password, which is Tracy yeah, well with an e spell with an e t r a c e y You get a head start on tickets before the rest of the general audience
也就是星期六，在加利福尼亚州洛杉矶的奥菲姆剧院，对吧？就像这个节目一样，我们不能公布嘉宾是谁，那将会是个惊喜，当晚现场揭晓。但对于你们这些一直以来对我们如此棒、如此亲切、如此充满爱意、一直在收听我们节目的听众来说，真正酷的事情是：我们想回馈你们一些东西，那就是可以提前买到门票。所以，如果你去smartlist.com并输入密码——密码是“Tracy”，对，带字母e的，拼写带个e：T-R-C-Y……呃，T-R-A-C-E-Y，你就能在普通公众之前提前买到门票。
So when you want to go and you want to buy tickets to this tour, you just you use the code tracy t r a c e y Right correct and it's starting today Monday 9 a.m. Eastern through Thursday at 10 p.m. Local time and Tickets go on sale to the public this Friday at 10 a.m. Local time right for all those venues and Thursday July 15th At 10 a.m. Local is the local venue pre-sale. So head to our website to buy tickets and you can get more information at smartlist.com and Again, Wednesday February 2nd Toronto Massey Hall Friday February 4th Boston, Massachusetts
所以，当你想去看这场巡演并买票时，你只需要使用代码“tracy”，即T-R-A-C-E-Y，对吧？没错。从今天星期一东部时间上午9点开始，一直持续到星期四当地时间晚上10点。门票将于本周五当地时间上午10点对公众公开发售，所有这些场馆都是如此。7月15日星期四当地时间上午10点是当地场馆的预售。所以请前往我们的网站买票，你可以在smartlist.com上获取更多信息。再次重申：2月2日星期三，多伦多马西音乐厅；2月4日星期五，马萨诸塞州波士顿……
Saturday February 5th Brooklyn, New York Chicago is February 8th Tuesday Wednesday Jason February 9th, you know where we're going just up the coast there, right? Just the coast of just up the up the eastern coast there to Wisconsin Yeah, I guess they didn't have a geography class in the in the in the trailer Universal and then Saturday February 12th back home in Los Angeles with our family and our friends and everybody at the Orvium Theater So guys we're so excited to bring the show to you and we're so So honored that this is even a possibility and we can't wait to have fun with y'all live I hope to see you there. Anyway, see you at the show. I'll see you guys at the show. We're gonna go together, right?
2月5日星期六，纽约布鲁克林；芝加哥是2月8日星期二。星期三，杰森，你知道我们要去哪儿，就沿着海岸线往上走，对吧？沿着东海岸一路向上去威斯康星州。对，我猜他们在房车里没上过地理课。环球影业。然后2月12日星期星期六，回到洛杉矶的家，和我们的家人、朋友以及奥菲姆剧院的每一个人在一起。所以，伙计们，我们非常兴奋能把这个演出带给你们，并且我们感到无比荣幸这竟然能够成为现实，我们迫不及待地想和你们一起在线下度过欢乐时光。希望能在现场见到你们。总之，演出见。我们演出见。我们要一起去，对吧？
We'll go together. Yeah, let's go together We'll travel together. We'll stay in the same hotel room together. Maybe stay in bed. We'll stay in the same hotel room We're gonna are you driving? We're gonna shake hands. We're gonna bump fist. We're gonna high five people. I know Sean's gonna take a take a bow Probably maybe a call or something. I'm gonna wear tails. I'm gonna wear tails Believe me. Sean's gonna have a spotlight on him. So he's gonna do a fucking song you watch That top hat and cane. I'm set. So anyway, so that's that's all the info that you need to have for our big tour I mean, that's it. Those are the dates in the cities and then the very exciting how great is it that the promo code is Tracy again
我们会一起去。对，我们一起去。我们一起旅行，一起住同一个酒店房间。也许睡同一个房间。我们要住同一个酒店房间。你会开车吗？我们会握手，我们会碰拳，我们会和大家击掌。我知道肖恩会上台鞠躬，可能还会来首独唱什么的。我要穿燕尾服。我要穿燕尾服，相信我。肖恩会有一束聚光灯照着他，所以他肯定会唱他妈的一首歌，你们就瞧好吧。高顶礼帽加手杖，我准备好了。总之，这就是你们需要了解的关于我们大巡演的所有信息。就是这样，这些就是日期和城市，最令人兴奋的是，宣传代码依然是“Tracy”，太棒了。
TRACY TRACY and that's where you can go and you can buy Buy your tickets. Buy them. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
T-R-A-C-Y，这就是你去买票的地方。去买吧。本期节目暂无评论。点击字幕中的任意句子即可发表评论。